what's up guys
bang bang it is lunch money time well
while she's trying to get rich the rest
of us just trying to get our lunch money
right
i'm here with her the best
literally the best do not forget the
lunch money's not sponsored by block
five
block five dot com slash pomp you can
earn up to eight point six percent apy
in an interest bearing account
you can buy itself crypto on the crypto
exchange or you can deposit crypto and
take out a us dollar loan against your
crypto crypto crypto collateral jesus i
can't talk
because there was so much alliteration
there for those of you that don't know
alliteration go look it up in the
dictionary your boy has
s.a.t words ready to go hello
go ahead fax blockfy.com go sign up they
got alliteration they got returns
uh from the yield they got all kinds of
crazy stuff go check it out block
five.com
pomp what other things do you got
i feel like you can't talk to them okay
so the fed on wednesday declined to let
up on its easy money policy despite an
economy
that it acknowledges is accelerating as
expected the u.s central bank decided to
keep short-term interest rates
anchored at zero as it buys at least 120
billion
dollars of bonds each month wow
120 billion per month hold on and fed
chairman jerome powell said the recovery
is
uneven and far from complete
well he noted that inflation pressures
could rise in the coming months
these one-time increases and prices are
likely to only have transitory effects
on inflation
not possible they keep saying that they
want sustained
levels of inflation over two percent
which would be high
inflation yet they're saying that the
high
inflation is transitory which one is it
is it sustained levels of over two
percent inflation
or is it transitory well you can't
have both that's the
no you can't i wrote all about it this
morning if you were a subscriber to the
newsletter at pumpletter.com you would
have read all about it
but the other thing is that they don't
know and that's okay just say you don't
know but this whole idea of pretending
like they've got the confidence to
control inflation
and manipulate it with a great degree of
accuracy is
garbage they have no clue so again are
we trying to get to over two percent
inflation in a sustained rate or
is it transit torque it can't be both
which is if they keep saying both
they're talking out of either side of
their mouth like hey listen tell us
what you think okay you know how apple
created
podcast subscriptions yes
spotify has now launched podcast
subscriptions
and creators would make more money than
they would
on apple what do we think is spotify
coming to eat apple's lunch what do you
think for breakfast
what do you think i think it's cool i
actually like spotify
unpopular view is that unpopular i like
them i like the ceo
i like the business i once interviewed
the very first investor on spotify
i thought everything he said made
logical sense
and um yeah it just daniel like is cool
so this might be a hot
opinion but i think an important one
here's the deal
if you think through exactly what
spotify did
spotify has been buying up a bunch of
podcasts spotify had the subscription
podcast in their back pocket
and they walked into the poker game and
they were like bam
they saw what apple was doing and what
they were offering creators and then
they were like just kidding look at us
they were like let me pull this out of
my back pocket bam pocket aces
what's up we ain't gonna take a fee and
apple's like we're gonna take 30
we're gonna take 30 and then all of a
sudden spotify like for the first two
years we're gonna take
zero goose egg nothing if you
want to come come to spotify zero i
think that's spotify
much more so than apple has been
thoughtful about their podcast strategy
spending the last two years buying all
these
podcast um platforms
and uh apple still has 50 of market
share though it does not matter it's
like spotify came out of nowhere and it
actually
challenged apple very successfully but
and
but nobody is listening to podcasts on
spotify
from a percentage basis on a global
basis spotify has like one to two
percent of the market yes
but as they get more exclusives like joe
rogan
and michelle obama and all these people
i think they have a shot
do we think that joe rogan's audience
grew or shrank since he went to spotify
probably shrank
i'm cheering for spotify i'm a big fan i
think that they generally are very
thoughtful
everything i've ever heard from daniel
eck has been really really compelling
but i do think that it's very hard to
overcome them
uh who almost said the m word but i'm
not gonna say it it's very hard to
overcome
a player in the market that is so
dominant they have 50
plus percent market share a mammoth no
it's like a board game monopoly
oh monopoly all right next that was like
a bad word
um that is a better california based
investment app
wealthfront is offering cryptocurrency
to its clients later in 2021
as it rides new retail interests
individual assets like
bitcoin and ether
everybody wants to get in on the crypto
game i don't know why i keep kind of
like coming over here yeah i don't know
because you're like
it's making me fuzzy if i'm back here so
i have to go
over here oh am i supposed to be looking
up here or down here up here
up here right here like right there put
your little finger away
wealth front everyone wants to get in on
crypto paypal square
whatever go use block five butterfly's
the sponsor so i'm gonna say go use them
wifi.com
next kevin o'leary kevin how did kevin
get it doing this now
ethereum is valuable but it's always
gonna be number two to bitcoin he says
but can we just talk about the
ridiculous this is our really
high level this is our really high level
i'm trying to show my things
don't look at my things oh my god
somebody's gonna did you see how
ridiculous
zoom in what do you have up there i got
some stuff
like that you have pocket yeah whatever
uh all right so all i gotta say is the
following
kevin o'leary i like your photo kevin
o'leary you're right that bitcoin is
number one and i just love the fact
that he went from
non-believer to full-on convert that now
there's multiple articles in cnbc
where kevin o'leary is spreading the
gospel shout out to kids i still
remember in 20 was it 17 or 18 when we
didn't have a couch
18. 2018 when we didn't have a couch uh
because of bitcoin into 19.
and and i remember like
reading these articles about kevin
o'leary and how he hates bitcoin and it
sucks and whatever i know he's like
i love bitcoin anthony want to go to
dinner with me let's go to lunch and i'm
like
i remember when i didn't have a couch i
like kevin
kevin is smart hopefully kevin will buy
lots of bitcoin
kevin kevin next
jeff bezos says space venture blue
origin will soon begin selling tickets
for a ride on its space tourism rocket
called new
shepard and the company announced in the
video
bezos said guys how exciting is this
come on
he says in the video it is unclear how
much tickets will cost how much do you
think it will cost to go to space
minimum quarter of a million yeah that's
what i was gonna say i was gonna say
200k
so probably like one bitcoin
i caught that if you were back at home
you didn't catch it
rewind cool yeah that's what i think 250
000
or more and maybe they'll even start
higher and then bring the price down
over time but do you think
like how much is your life worth if this
rocket employee
like i just don't know you get in a car
every day yeah but it's different
why is it different because i'm in
charge of my future jeff
bezos uh have you seen some of the uber
drivers no oh my god guys miami
okay wait can i complain i'm gonna
complain to the people
we were in an uber one time and i get
really car sick and like nauseous
and it was like a hundred degrees and
this man could
there he did not want to turn up the ac
so anthony very politely said
hey sir excuse me could you do you mind
turning up the ac
and he said if you're in miami you need
to learn how to sweat
and i was like okay so i was like well
can i open the window i just need some
air
and he was like no and if we weren't in
a rush i was getting out of that car so
fast
we rolled down the window yeah but and
then because i was gonna throw up it's
better
it's either go down the window or me
throw up in the car and
the second choice is not a very good one
okay
ready welcome to my life gringis
gringenstein is asking it's ask lunch
money time hashtag
i kind of miss moist now never thought
i'd see this
oh i definitely missed moist moist
shout out i hope you leave a great
comment today if you leave a great
comment
just he's active he's just got another
pseudonymous identity probably
do you think it's jake from state farm
no hello
okay hold on let me ask the question
bitcoin is touted as a great store of
value and not as a currency if a perfect
decentralized currency came to fruition
would a store of value even
be necessary p.s this is my third
attempt to get noticed
gringis if you ask dumb questions you're
going to get noticed
and now you got noticed because you
asked a dumb question
bitcoin is the perfect decentralized
currency
that's why so here's how currency works
i'm joking it wasn't really a stupid
question question
question uh if you think of a currency
you need to have a store of value and
then it becomes a medium of exchange
you usually cannot have a medium of
exchange if you first do not have a
store of value
and so a currency medium of exchange
store of value
bitcoin is obviously a fantastic store
value because over time your purchasing
power continues to appreciate
it is also being used as a medium of
exchange
because it will do over 5 trillion
dollars in on-chain transaction volume
not exchanges
purely in the payment system itself of
bitcoin
and therefore bitcoin is the best
perfect decentralized digital currency
do you smell that it smells like cocoa
puffs
do you smell that like cocoa puffs i
wish that i could say i farted because
that would be funny
but i didn't fart is it no my coffee
what is that somebody is having cocoa
puffs around
here and i will find out where
all right who do i live in literally
smells all right that's it we'll see you
guys tomorrow goodbye
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block 5 so go check them
out there's a link in the description
that you can click on
i'm an investor a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block flies my second favorite thing in
the world behind polina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to 8.6
interest on an interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to 8.6 interest on a deposit in an
interest bearing account go do your own
research
there's risks associated but 8.6 is
pretty compelling
so click on the link in the description
say thanks to the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends